[Música]
[Aplausos]
el pensador de rodin
estaría pensando el pensador de rodin
sostengo que no somos seres racionales
somos seres emocionales que razonan que
no es lo mismo
claro el pensador de rodin obviamente
está pensando y dio como cierro esto
porque sé que biológicamente y psico
biológicamente no somos racionales que
lo somos es obvio es provocativo lo que
digo pero somos seres emocionales que
razonan no es lo mismo entonces fui a
ver la historia del pensador de rodin y
cuando le proponen a rod en hacer un
conjunto escultórico de lo que era la
puerta del infierno del dante alighieri
él lo hizo
y arriba puso esto pero no lo llamo el
pensador lo llamo el poeta solamente
después cuando él sacó ese conjunto
escultórico lo llamó el pensador pero lo
inicial que en rhoden tenían la mente es
que se trataba de un poeta y un poeta
como un alfarero maneja el barro un
poeta maneja emociones y sentimientos me
gusta pensar que somos
seres emocionales que razonan
cómo empieza la historia qué tiempo
evolutivo tiene esta historia vamos a
proyectarnos a 4 millones de años atrás
podríamos ir más lejos podríamos ir a 13
mil 800 millones de años atrás con el
big-bang casi nada más que hidrógeno y
de golpe todo estalla y nace la materia
el tiempo la energía la gravedad y todo
se expande se expande y 4500 millones de
años atrás aparece el planeta tierra y
se va enfriando y 3 mil 800 millones de
años atrás aparece nuestro primer
tatarabuelo el primer ser viviente una
bacteria y 500 años atrás 500 millones
de años atrás aparece la primera neurona
y así somos el resultado evolutivo y
llega un momento un poco más atrás de 4
millones de años atrás caminamos en
cuatro patas justo antes de ponernos de
pie
y ya teníamos una emoción el miedo
porque el miedo nos protegía nos
protegía de los predadores nos daba una
defensa cuando evolutivamente fue
avanzando el tiempo y nos pusimos de pie
macho y hembra tuvieron que estar juntos
para cuidar a las crías que nacían con
poca mielinización cerebral no tenían
que cuidar la naturaleza la evolución
darwiniana o la primera de las causas
selecciona un sentimiento ya no una
emoción el amor para qué macho y hembra
estén más tiempo juntos para poder criar
a ese que llegó al mundo después aparece
la empatía que es querer al otro y
entenderlo y cuando se hace en conjunto
de golpe aparece el altruismo y ya
tenemos miedo amor empatía altruismo
millones de años atrás y aproximadamente
unos 200 o 300 mil años atrás si moría
alguien y que ahí acá éramos grupos
nómades y al morir veíamos que estaba
muerto y lo dejábamos estábamos en el
tiempo presente en lo inmanente y
aproximadamente 160 mil años atrás acá
casi nada de tiempo moría alguien lo
miraron y dijeron algún lugar va a ir
entonces lo enterraron lo enterraron con
sus enseres arco flecha morral porque lo
iba a usar en el más allá nació la fe
una función biológica se pasó de lo
inmanente a 160 mil años atrás se pasó a
lo trascendente es una función biológica
evolutiva a algún lado
todo esto son emociones y sentimientos
recién nada acá 70 mil años atrás
aparece la cognición el entendimiento
aparece el pensamiento aparece el lóbulo
frontal el prefrontal nuestra capacidad
de juicio intelecto abstracción
pero fíjense 4 millones de años de
evolución
y en 70.000 años de razón es obvio que
somos racionales pero me gusta decir que
somos más emocionales que racionales y
evolutivamente uno puede darse cuenta
que el neuro es el sistema nervioso lo
que está adentro del cerebro es lo que
llamamos cerebro límbico que está
relacionado con las emociones uno podría
ser casi una metáfora en este sentido
les propongo que hagan esto hagan esto
así y con estos dedos hagan esto así y
ahora hacen esto así y rodean el dedo
gordo y ponen la mano así al ponerlo así
hicieron la metáfora de un cerebro
sucede que estas son las
circunvoluciones el lóbulo frontal la
capacidad destrucción ejecución lógica
lenguaje razonamiento de esto nos
vanagloriamos energía igual masa por
velocidad de la luz al cuadrado
extraordinario pero debajo subyace
evolutivamente el cerebro límbico el
emocional de 4 millones de años de
evolución claro que nos vanagloriamos de
esto y es como decía francisco bernardi
el poeta amigo de borges porque después
de todo he comprendido que lo que el
árbol tiene de florido
pensamiento energía igual más aprobé los
ida de la luz al cuadrado
después de todo he comprendido que lo
que el árbol tiene de florido vive de lo
que tiene sepultado y me parece que es
así que básicamente somos emociones y
sentimientos pero que es una emoción una
emoción es una vivencia que tiene rostro
no es lo mismo emoción que sentimiento
la emoción de miedo la más antigua es
una vivencia que tiene rostro
es parte de un programa neurobiológico
básicamente hay más pero podemos decir
que las emociones son miedo alegría asco
y la tristeza sorpresa y servían para
comunicarnos como lo hacemos hoy del
lenguaje no verbal todavía no hablábamos
era una vivencia
para que pongas bien cara a alegría y
ahora miren al de al lado
miren el de al lado qué cara tiene qué
cara tiene el de al lado de alegría
porque ustedes lo ven y es una
comunicación no verbal
el miedo quizás diría que es lo
contrario cuando haya alegría uno está
muy lejos del miedo de la traición de la
inseguridad dice cuando esté en esa
alegría cómo te sentís que estás cómodo
seguro no hay seguridad con alegría qué
cara pone en nuestros políticos en una
foto de campaña de alegría para que los
votemos de una forma empática de generar
comunicación que es una emoción una
vivencia que tiene el rostro que no se
aprende las traemos de 4 millones de
años de evolución un ciego de nacimiento
pone cara de miedo o cara de alegría
cuando sienten miedo de alegría y nunca
labios es parte de un programa biológico
otra característica de la emoción que es
que se intensa con fuerte repercusión
física taquicardia transpiración algo se
te mueve y dura poco tiempo
la emoción es un evento público se
transmite al entorno evolutivamente
después apareció el amor para
mantenernos juntos y eso es un
sentimiento ya eso es otra cosa es una
cuestión más avanzada
el amor como fue selecta dow por la
naturaleza ya es un conjunto de
vivencias emocionales que tramitadas por
las funciones cognitivas se convierten
en lo que llamamos sentimiento que es
mucho más organizado tiene menor
intensidad corpórea que la emoción no
tiene un rostro específico pero puede
durar mucho tiempo a veces como toda la
vida
amor odio culpa vergüenza orgullo
altruismo
todos esos son sentimientos las
emociones eran un evento público los
sentimientos son un evento privado es
algo que uno tiene adentro como que está
escondido y todo esto es claramente
evolutivo lo tenemos porque ahí tiene
que estar cada cosa que tenemos están
ahí porque tiene que estar porque los
agujeros analizan para abajo
los que nacían con agujeros para arriba
cuando llovía se llenaba de agua se
infectaban se morían y no tenían
descendencia
porque tenemos las cejas tenemos las
cejas para que no caiga el agua y la
transpiración no quedar ciegos por
infección y tener descendencia siempre
fue así somos seres cazadores miramos
para adelante y cómo están las orejas
para adelante porque hagamos esto les
invito a una prueba hagan esto así igual
que yo eso es así usted también es así
hagan esto mientras yo hablo y en un
momento dado ustedes me están escuchando
están escuchando cualquiera que haga
esto en cualquier lugar escuchan los
sonidos de un modo están haciendo así
como el topo gigio hagan esto hagan esto
así y de golpe van a hacer algo pero no
lo hagan ahora lo voy a hacer yo solo
nadie mueva las manos en un momento le
voy a decir que hagan esto pero no lo
hagan ahora me explique no lo vayan a
hacer ahora pero en un momento le voy a
decir que hagan eso está bien bueno
entonces mientras yo sigo haciendo esto
sigo haciendo esto hago esto y biden
mira y da vuelta ahora da vuelta a la
mano fíjate cómo cambio el sonido y cómo
cambió el mundo te das cuenta acabamos
de descubrir las orejas
en la clasificación de emociones y
sentimientos
que hay varias se pueden clasificar en
positivas y negativas en psicobiología
negativo no quiere decir malo quiere
decir que te alejas de algo que genera
aversión mientras que las positivas
quiere decir que simplemente te acercas
a algo entonces una emoción positiva es
la alegría un sentimiento positivo es el
amor la ira es negativa la tristeza
negativa pero no es mala en sí misma
tenéis que tener tristeza para elaborar
una perdida si eso corresponde eso está
bien pero es positivo o negativo lo
positivo te atrae a las cosas lo
negativo te aleja de las cosas vos tenes
aparte toda emoción implica emovere
viene de mover implica un movimiento
imaginen un caracol de jardín visto los
caracoles que van así con los tentáculos
la punta tiene los ojos lo tocas que
hace caracol hagan como el caracol que
hace cargo del otro caso se mete para
dentro sí no
eso es una emoción negativa y es
protectiva ahora si ese caracol en esa
misma noche encuentra otro caracol y se
enamora van a tener un apareamiento
enamorado cuando tener un apareamiento
que va a durar entre 4 y 7 horas
más respeto por el caracol
y siendo ocurrió pensar sobre esta línea
de que no somos seres racionales sino
seres emocionales que razonan que como
hace 13 mil 800 millones de años esto
aparece que hace con una bola de
hidrógeno y se produce el big-bang y esa
expansión y todo es así evolutivo y está
simplemente porque tiene que estar
noto que de golpe tres colores los
retinianos los colores primarios
retinianos determinan todos los colores
la naturaleza rojo verde azul
y si a las emociones positivas le damos
esto metafórico le damos colores y si
las emociones y sentimientos negativos
les damos colores oscuros se me ocurre
pensar que no estoy viendo personas se
me ocurre pensar que estoy viendo
licuadoras
porque sostengo que somos una mezcla no
somos lo que pensamos somos lo que
sentimos y quienes nos rodean son los
que sienten no lo que pensamos o ellos
piensan nos constituyen 4 millones de
años de evolución esa es la gran
diferencia somos una mezcla de colores
que determinan nuestra emocionalidad y
metafóricamente si se mezclan los tres
colores básicos en igual cantidad el
rojo el verde y el azul se determinará
qué color el blanco y la ausencia de
esto determinará el negro no es que esté
mal tener emociones o sentimientos
negros o negativos porque la tristeza lo
es pero en la medida que tiene que estar
si logré explicarme lo que me gusta
sostener es que de algún modo somos un
batido emocional con distintos colores
que van a determinar esos colores van a
determinar de acuerdo a sean positivos o
negativos coloreados más oscuros o más
claros van a determinar un color del
licuado distinto no estoy viendo
personas estoy viendo la licuadora
y me parece que estamos un licuado
me parece que cada uno de nosotros somos
un licuado y nos identificamos por la
proporción de emociones y sentimientos
que nos habitan cuánto de ira cuánto de
miedo cuánto de amor cuánto de odio
cuánto de culpa cuánto de vergüenza y se
me ocurre pensar también metafóricamente
que si ese licuado pareciera de color
pareciera de emociones y sentimientos
positivos en lo absoluto y todo lo que
lo genera todo lo que lo constituye
serían negativos el licuado sería de
color negro y si eso es así
probablemente tendríamos esto hitler es
un licuado negro
pero si en cambio se juntan todos los
colores muy probablemente tengamos esto
la madre teresa de calculta es
metafórico pero en el medio de ambos
extremos
estamos todos nosotros entre
hitler todo negativo y lo que podemos
decir mezclas de emociones y
sentimientos positivos
les cuento una historia
david y goliat david era hijo de jesse
vivía en belén los israelitas entran en
combate con los pueblos del mar o
filisteos que se manda a sus hijos a
combate pero el más chiquito eran el
fénix que no podía combatir se quedó
cuidando las ovejas las características
de david es que tenía un enorme fe fe en
su dios no importa si dios existe el
tenía fe en su dios para él totalmente
válido van al frente de combate sus
hermanos y un día el padre le dice bueno
te quedarás simplemente cuidando las
ovejas empezó a aprender con una honda a
ausentar los lobos y un día le dice
lleva estos granos al frente de combate
y estos quesos a tus hermanos y al
comandante del batallón va y se entera
que todos los días un gigante de más de
tres metros con armadura
con escudo con lanza y escudero
amenazaba al ejército de israel diciendo
que si alguien le ganaba en combate
serían libres y saben que el quiso
combatir pero no le dejaron era un
alfeñique habló con el rey saúl su rey
el rey decidió que combate le dio la
ropa para combatir pero no se podía
levantar del peso de la armadura se
volvió a poner la túnica tomó su morral
tres guijarros y una honda fue el frente
de combate y tras las líneas enemigas
salió un gigante de más de tres metros
con armadura con escudo con lanza y
escudero
seguramente david tuvo emociones y
sentimientos tuvo un licuado seguramente
tuvo sorpresa al verlo de golpe seguro
tuvo miedo y tuvo asombro en el instante
que lo vio pero también tenía fe el
gigante se ríe y dice instantes más voy
a arrojar tus entrañas a las aves
rapaces del cielo
david tomo su onda un guijarro dio tres
vueltas le pega acá y el gigante que hay
muerto instantáneamente frente al piso
ese es el resultado del color del
licuado
no somos seres racionales somos seres
emocionales que razonan y para conocer a
las personas y para conocernos a
nosotros mismos es necesario saber el
color del licuado de las emociones y
sentimientos que nos constituyen gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]